what is it about thank you I like
grinding I like very grindy games I like
i have what i like to call purple fever
which is when I have to have nothing but
epic or legendary type gear which I have
accomplished on my first character my
Titan
it's like a never ending cycle you can
always do better you can always have
better that's what life's like the grind
life I enjoyed it on being open to
wanting to evolve and better yourself
that's what meets like it's definitely a
mental thing though like you think in
the game like like you're also getting
better the game too yeah I'd like to
think that sometimes I don't feel like I
am I don't know I just have a lust whole
cheese ever lust for like being the best
and like trying we're trying to be the
best and I don't know what it is about
the gear that makes me want to chase it
but I like have to have it like right
now for example right if you look at my
character like I have two blue items
right these clothes on these boots in
that disgusts personally it disgusts me
you have to be purple or yellow after
not purple yellow then I'm doing
something wrong in the game
well with Lisa's g-dub but it's like
that delayed gratification right because
you're not actually all those n-grams
you pick up are just then currency that
you take to the Crypt are yeah but and
then you're grinding him up yeah but the
items are like that the encrypted items
are kind of like a lotto scratcher right
you you kind of know what you're getting
with it in some regard but then you
don't know if you're gonna hit the
jackpot or not right and so you get the
gear right there's a satisfaction and
like having it equipped but then do you
like experience satisfaction from like
showing its other people like strutting
around the tower with it on or more
critically like using it in the actual
game I don't feel like a braggart coming
into the office but it's cool to show
you know you Shan ji like hey I got
chatter white the chatter white shader a
big shade a pic shader you guys got a
kick out of it too because you've never
seen it right so yeah like I don't leave
it to getting a kick out of looking at
your loot no that's cool that's not my
intent when I'm doing it it's just a
trickle down effect of as I'm doing it
that's one of the cool things that
happens to come about
the guns eventually matter and that's
why you're on the chase to get some of
these exotic type weapons is because
they have effects on them that normal
guns don't have like my assault rifle
that I have right now that the second
half of the clip does double the damage
which is like insane and the thing about
that that makes it cool is like you
don't get any of those kind of guns
before you even you know before you get
to this stage of the game and after
doing the raid there's even us you know
primary weapons that have elemental
damage so those kind of things start to
change the game a little bit or at least
how you think about it and that makes it
more fun for me do you think that well
you should have put more of that cool
stuff in earlier going to make it like
let things be cooler earlier on or do
you think it's like I feel about having
to have waited this long and then grind
to actually get it
well for me it's not that bad like the
concepts not that bad because I played a
lot of MMOs I know what it's like to
have to work really hard to get items
and the payoff is usually very huge but
the thing I've been harking this whole
time is just that it's not for everybody
right the time you can spend a lot of
time and still not get anything but I
mean the good i mean in terms of your
question I think yeah it would have been
more fun for the general masses if you
know they had items like that for them
to use right off the bat but at the same
time I feel like that's what helps me
chase these things is because you can't
get that fat easily and it's really
rewarding when you get it
you